isso é uma das coisas mais bizarras que
encomendei um lixo com pedro fazendo 32
um outro ato pessoal de quem falar que
seja muito bem vindo buscar mais um
vídeo e vejam só que nós temos aqui em
cima da mesa uma caixinha de whisky
claro é personalizada eu fiz esta caixa
juntamente com a voz misteriosa e que é
e que só que eu tenho é que nessa caixa
são todas as encomendas do mês que eu
fiz do estoque do mês não porque o ano
muito consumista não isso é bastante os
terceiros compras equivalentes é uma
semana eu tenho aqui muita coisa pode
explicar aí
aí conheci coisas inúteis podem podem
ser coisas fúteis também podem podem ser
coisas que não têm nada a ver
então vou mostrar aqui pra vocês pessoal
e todas as salas só se quiserem ver mais
contínuo lojas chinesas se quiserem ver
já de si muito aqui embaixo combine com
os vossos inimigos até eu começar só
confio uso tem noção mas teve um vídeo
de ontem eu vi o que eu comprasse não é
isso o que eu comprei uns mil euros foi
mil euros mil mais - ninguém sabe
eu estou muito excitado não mexer em
muita gente perguntou se comprar não é
confiável pra mim é confiável ou nunca
falharam no entanto vocês têm que ter
muita atenção quando encomendou alguma
coisa porque lá diz um preço imaginem um
produto custa 1 dólar quando vocês
adicional ao sexto depois vão confirmar
quanto é que o sport às vezes pensam que
é um dogma depois ficar triste porque os
portes e 28 na verdade o produto custa 4
dólares e os colocam a 1 e quando você
seleciona já vários transportes então eu
tinha uma tática de marketing e dois só
tem pretensão mas o site super confiável
já para não falar das coisas que são
graça as coisas claras o sport também
está muita coisa lá que diz que é frio
mas com as nossas pagam impostos de 1
dólar
mas aquilo não é frio e nublado custa 1
dólar então lá e coisinhas que na hora
de gemas e depois
saiu que eu não vou ver já porque eu
quero 40 em vídeo então bora lá que tem
que os óculos eu acho que foi uma das
coisas freire uma das coisas free kick
ass com um dólar eo albendazol os
meninos gostam só história deixou olic
que instruiu o livrete quebrou um dogma
eu acho que tá bom
acho que vou postar as fotos do ensaio
online e vistoso e agradável tudo
influenciou na queda
temos aqui um 'golpe' bem gordinho só eu
vou ter atenção aqui pra não fora a
namorada na época eu já sei se vocês
souberem morada vão perceber que todos
em casa não é que eu me importo mas já
aconteceu nos inscritos virem criticar a
porta o cara e sem parar eu não façam
isso se não abrir a porta porque eu não
consigo não posso topo a tensão no país
natal misteriosa aéreos que um da maia
os presentes vão perceber eu realmente
estou mais luvas pra cá eu encomendo aí
umas luvas para escovar os o que é em
vez dos 4 atípica escova nesta uma luva
passes calção e contei que estes bilhões
o alexandre borracha pegou muito bem
isso o que promete trazer aqui vamos
ajustar isso aí
[Música]
olha aí ainda não apanhou pela mas eu
acho que isso não servem pra apanhar o
pelos demais francisco vai para pentear
para soltar o pew pré para desfazer os
nós mas para apanhar a primeira muito do
teu é e é esse mesmo que tenha uma
escova nova é muito né deixou para
gravar vídeo deixou para gravá la a essa
influência do uso que o influenciou
só a próxima coisa aqui o que é está
pesado
será que aquilo é lojas em meu entender
está há dois meses atrás
como podem ver a encomendas que chegam
muito atrasadas mas cheias o que quer
que deixe em gravar o vídeo eu quero ver
as coisas só isso é uma das coisas mais
bizarras que encomendam isso só comentei
em baixo o que vocês acham que isto é
boca
também não acho que é porque pode ser um
objeto futura mas não é só o que eu
comprei que é uma armadilha pecuários o
pra mim os mais pequenos obviamente que
não vou usar isso para caçar né mas eu
comprei porque isso é mais ou menos uma
réplica daquelas medidas duras que os
peões assim que funciona e pega o russo
e eu vou pra isso porque só porque eu
pensava em fazer com que uma série no
canal o texto esta armadilha onde eu
coloco aqui várias coisas e vamos estar
aqui já é um texto parece olha aproximar
e próxima aí como incrível isto é vamos
fazer o teste com cenoura pra vocês
terem noção do quão potente esta
armadilha o que é e como tem também
embaixo quer que eu faça um vídeo a
história que outras coisas querem que eu
coloco aqui uma maçã
o iphone não sei
isso aí vai ter que ir lá e é isso em
321 ou não depois nowruz inicial e salto
no meio play fechou no mesmo local só
tem aqui muito mais coisas na caixa que
foi regular até o fim deste vídeo
portanto existe até o fim mas eu agora
quero me apresentar aqui uma novidade
uma coisa que me deu muito orgulho em
fazer a sério é que temos pessoal o
nosso laís mas só o seu talento com as
áreas foram nós fizemos aqui este
conjunto dos planos eugenia são
realmente os mais incríveis e eu já
tinha feito um vídeo fazer promoção
microsoft não compro eu quero mostrar o
que tem aqui dentro que vamos comprovar
que realmente eles são os melhores só
aqui dentro temos vários planos temos o
da via do ppe o meu é que neste livro
tentar fazer o meu pai além disso vocês
têm 27 com chute para fazer aqui com o
kit formas mais incríveis e tem 12
atividades portanto não vai faltar
diversão em nossa casa
peça ajuda ao vosso pai a vossa mãe de
vitor também e agora vai vir aqui e vou
tentar construir o meu silicone pra mim
é o mais incrível é que nesta caixa sem
sombra de dúvida e você já não conseguiu
porque mas o compreenderem as nossas
conclusões passam quiserem o meu melhor
aqui
acho acho curiosa 25 mil é o melhor que
tem aqui dentro desta caixa os nossos
siga se vocês podem colar em qualquer
lugar que tem os kits têm os líquidos
têm as coisas que deixam os olhos
brilhantes portanto é muito útil vai
colocar os proteção obviamente é que vai
uma embalagem com amido de milho para
dar consistência ao flamengo é que nós
temos a bandeja para colocar o flamengo
fazer as misturas pauzinhos tem muito
material sair foram vocês estão doidos
vocês construíram um novo brinquedo que
é que se passa é que também tem um
livrinho com a nossa cara é que
distribuem também tem impacto sobre nós
portanto aqui dentro vocês vão encontrar
conteúdo exclusivo sobre nós os três vão
salvar a nossa proteção
as luas segurança sempre primeiro ela
falou que é preciso dois copinhos de
amido de milho café
agora precisamos de 80 mil litros de
água
[Risadas]
agora pessoal com o pt vamos colocar dez
gotas de corante azul no 1 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 10 cc 10 tipos e 12 12 e 14 é o que
vocês quiserem os levou a só o uhuu eu
acho que vai ficar muitos 1
agora só vou inventar um pouco e vou
colocar aqui este brilhantes falei isso
você fica qualquer foco assim mais
bonitinho mais brilhante e agora vamos
fazer a mistura e vamos ver o que vai
ser daqui
como podem ver se movimentar os km e
está completamente sólido da para
manusear ok mas se eu deixar em cima da
minha mão por um segundo não vai ter
como seu som equipe porém só 321 está
completamente clique ganhar outra vez
vai ficar duro e uma adaptação fácil
assim forma estranha por isso vou deixar
assim o troféu não quiser é só a chance
de obter um foi uma voz misteriosa com
ele agora só tirar as ruguinhas meu mãos
limpas e suaves prefeito por foi então
já sabe vocês podem encontrar este que
está à venda em todas as lojas das áreas
fabril em todos os shoppings onde está
em estoril está à venda espero que vocês
gostem para então continuar aqui abrindo
as coisas ruins para lá que mais produz
mostrar vazio isso este que foi 5
dólares eu acho eu não sei se usares com
notas reais
não sei se cabe baixo ou o op incrível
já vem com nada super gum estava em
combina um barulho estranho é claro o
momento essas coisas nunca bem com
pilhas
a equipe também alguns dólares
obviamente que são dólares falsos né
olha é isso que eles se percam também
misteriosa está pronta
32 o olha aí tá tudo cheio de notas
olha aqui imagina aqui embaixo
eu estou ok são 15 dólares que valeram a
pena total muito curto eu entrar notas
aqui dentro que tem aqui dentro
são 24 as obras que incluem daí porque
eu quero usar este porta chaves como
essa só de roupa não é tipo usado aqui e
por que durará que neste caso ações e
fica assim acho que é bom o outro é a
mesma coisa
aí fica muito difícil mas também foi um
dólar foi frito eu paguei o sport com
dólar
méxico o equipamento está muito bem
feito eu não costumo comprar coisas
testa estavam em presídios de chefs
roupa em si existe é que eu arrisquei
porque era só um dólar e está muito bem
feita bem cozido mas coisas que não sei
que mais mais uma embalagem torcida não
deve ser a mesma loja até é porque eu
isso é uma loja depois tem várias lojas
que vendem coisas né paris vários
cursinhos utilizadores ao espírito
realmente eu comprei nada é que dentro
em nada
é possível com preço do propósito
registrado 40 só está o estádio está à
venda um produto que não é nada eu
realmente ver nem nada a ver esta
cápsula aqui que não têm na embalagem
tudo é exatamente solo crise é na sem
querer nada em inglês foi deposto ruas
regra tem pra pessoa que tem tudo já se
você estiver em um amigo que é rico tem
muito dinheiro que já tem tudo que já
tem iphone já tentava já têm pc já têm
tudo carro casa tudo vocês podem ver se
estava semi porque eu não fiz nada
próximo lavagem da embalagem grande
pelos vistos já está aberta senhor dos
correios o que vocês a nossa época
algumas vezes eu desconfio do que o
produto então eu vá ver em que é isto
o rosto e cobre que comprei pra fazer
pra mim concluí meu é muito realista
essa cobra mas pela imagem deu isso eu
acho que eu fiz o que eu comprei eu eu
acho que tenha encomendado uma cobra que
eu pensei que era maior e era meio
insuflável pra deixar ali tipo ou no
jardim ou o que a porta de casa eu não
pensei que fosse assim pequena que fosse
tão sólido no entanto está bem feita
tava enfrenta cinco estrelas
eu até tenho sorte por meio da lei o
próximo como está o que já sabem que vai
incluir a cobra né
já sabe oque próximo pois aqui da wii u
é ter que o frágil frágil eu tenho aqui
um ordem tem que proibir a andar de
skate tem que pregar ozu área restrita
não entrar stop não fumar um take e
outro em chinês
eu tenho muita coisa aqui eu estou um
dólar 5050 cinco anos não próxima coisa
talvez essa já estava também o que se
passa é que eu estou com raiva porque
foi melhor em tudo isso
não há exigências encomendas mais
misteriosas no canal
bom isso é um novo prêmio há coisas que
eu não lembro que eu comprei porque eu
compro registrar aqui mas eu não
o bicho estranho eu vou detonar tem o
gol de tomar gol da etapa também não é
uma personagem muito no fim a japonesa
de ônibus e do anima e vamos analisar
desde o começo para crianças não fiquem
muito fim de aprender com a voz
misteriosa incrível
[Aplausos]
o time espanhol
eu não sei se era possível abrir assim
julga não vai se opor ao site será a a a
uma carta já não lembro e fácil estamos
vendo aqui está aqui para ter uma carta
do baralho mas leão isso na verdade é um
chute que me foi confiado perigoso
eu não sei se elas se atirar contra o
mar para encontrar alguma coisa eu acho
que este beta é bem capaz que o intuito
é esse é um chique né eu vou tentar
estar aqui já na janela por aplicar
força 321 spotoni isso aqui ok ok e
outra com pouca força vou tentar com
mais força agora só província vai
atravessar a caixa 132 um outro lado ou
do outro lado então já sei que o filme
por dentro da caixa e vamos ver tipos
ela passa dentro 3 215 gols pra este
entrou que por vezes ao pouco cima
meu deus tudo está a correr muito mal
aqui por alguma razão de uma embalagem
vazia
não sei porque quando a equipe caiu
o que nós temos aqui então médico fire é
o que nós fizemos aqui não isso vai
produzir uma cor vibrante porque eu
comprei podem provar se deitarem no fogo
fizeram uma fogueira ao churrasco assim
e chama automaticamente vai ficar com
couro eu vou tentar fazer é colocar
algum podem aqui dentro vamos acender o
isqueiro se chama dos quero alterar a
cor é porque isso funciona numa coisa
melhor
eu caí acharem que podem sustentar o
vício se movendo de uma chama mercy 31 o
verde verde taveiro
por isso fica aceso o conteúdo é
inflamável eu acho isso aqui é
inflamável mesmo ficou o governo olha
isso tá medo
incrível olha pessoal está comprovado
funciona valeu pelo dinheiro se usar
isso em algo churrasco assim a chama vai
atrasar o corpo perfeito eu acho que uma
das coisas mais incríveis que vai aqui
hoje nesta embalagem no difícil a
criação de falta uma uma uma embalagem
será a nossa última imagem que será que
é isto o que eu andei comprar não isso
eu e esta é a minha carga um ovo
olha isso o que falta à nossa
responsabilidade comenta embaixo o item
que vocês acharam mais inútil e o mais
incrível se eu com curva eu vou deixar
lhe que nos vossos comentários até então
é só fazer explicaram que decidiram
investir muito mais que isso é muito
importante mesmo eu vou tentar ao máximo
colocar vídeos mais regularmente aqui só
tem aqui um desafio pra vocês vão lá no
lecs ap mandou um link para os vossos
inimigos e não digo nada só como um
álbum que mantém sua primeira criação
deus já sabem muito importante em todos
os postos a história tem nosso grupo que
está havendo portanto por vai ter de vir
tons e e só fique bem e até a próxima